Ce garçon tout stressé va donc épouser ma sœur.
Et mais sérieux poto, t'es vraiment vilain.
Qu'est-ce que tu fous avec elle sérieux ?
Vire ta caméra là !
Fais gaffe, c'est à mon grand-père.
Il a filmé le mariage de mes parents avec ça.
Arthur ?
Je perpétue la tradition là.
Laisse-moi faire du slam à la cérémonie.
Mais je t'ai déjà dit non.
C'est poétique.
Non mais t'es un témoin. Fais des trucs de témoin.
Enfin, je sais pas ce qu'ils font mais les témoins ne slament pas !
Mais parce que t'as pas compris que ça va être un interlude poétique.
Ous', filme !
Je me lève en pleine cérémonie.
Les gens, ils se disent "Tiens, il va faire un discours, ça va être chiant."
Comme d'hab'. Là, je sors mon portable : "Quoi ? Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?"
Et là, bam !
On est ici pour célébrer l'union de deux personnes que j'aime.
Nul.
Rien de servile,
quand il s'agit de servir un frérot pas de problème.
Les gens veulent s'ambiancer...
Arthur ?
Ça s'ambiance pas ?
Bah non, ça, ça ambiance pas.
Arthur !
Je...
Je suis désolé, je peux plus...
Je peux plus.
Tu peux plus quoi ? Enfin...
Tout ça, là... tout ce truc, tout ce mariage...
c'est trop, j'arrive pas. Je peux plus.
Attends, t'es en train de dire quoi là ?
Je suis en train de dire qu'on se marie pas, on arrête.
Je peux plus !
C'est trop pour moi, j'arrive pas.
Et tu me dis... attends, tu viens tu me dis...
le jour...
Non mais oui, bien sûr.
Super !
Je suis pas censé ne pas te voir en robe de mariée ?
Il n'y pas une tradition ?
Oh ça va !
Bon allez hop, ça c'est fait.
Maintenant je vais aller rechecker pour voir si tout le monde est en place.
Voilà faisons ça. Hey !
Fais en sorte qu'Isa et ma mère soient pas à côté, s'il te plaît.
Isa ?
Isa, ma tante.
Viens me montrer,
tu crois que je connais tous les beaufs de ta famille ou quoi ?
Ok.
Bah faisons ça.
Après, elle est pas beauf hein.
Enfin, elle a une genre de crête mais elle est pas...
Je suis tellement fier de toi sœurette !
Mais comment ça se fait que t'es aussi détente ?
Ça va, je suis pas...
Ils disent que quand t'es stressé de ouf,
tu fais genre tu rigoles, t'es détente et tout.
Alors qu'au fond, ça va pas.
Oh ! Ça y est !
Le roi des théories foireuses commence à s'exprimer là.
Non, mais il a pas tort.
Attends, c'est quand même le plus beau jour de ta vie et,
t'es limite en mode pause café quoi.
Je suis pas en mode... non pas du tout.
Non, j'aborde mon mariage à l'image
de notre couple avec moi et Arthur, tu vois ?
Genre...
cool...
détente...
très amoureux aussi, tu vois.
Bon, c'est pas le plus beau jour de ma vie mais...
Ça fera forcément partie d'un des plus beaux jours de ma vie, ouais.
Ouais, je vois ce qu'elle veut dire.
Le jour où je vais me marier, parce que ça va arriver,
ok ?
Ça sera pas le plus beau jour de ma vie.
Loin de là. Même pas le deuxième.
Même pas le troisième en vrai.
J'étais là, en direct à la télé.
Quand Goku, il s'est transformé en Saiyan. J'étais dedans.
J'étais là.
Ah ouais, donc toi tu classes les plus beaux jours de ta vie ?
Ouais.
Ok.
Et donc du coup, c'est quoi
le plus beau jour de ta vie, genre le top of the pop ?
Top of the pop ?
J'étais prêt à défoncer la ville !
C'est un rêve ça !
Ça peut pas être le plus beau jour de ta vie !
Ouais mais quand j'ai fait le rêve, c'était le plus beau jour de ma vie.
Oui mais le plus beau jour de ta vie,
c'est censé être le plus beau jour de ta vraie vie.
Pas la plus belle nuit de ta vie.
Ok, mais quand j'ai fait le rêve,
c'était en plein jour,
après le déjeuner.
Donc ça peut compter comme un jour.
Donc comme le plus beau jour de ma vie.
Donc en fait...
Isa, c'est celle qui a de la moustache
et qu'on a mis au deuxième rang là ?
Oui.
Enfin non, c'est un duvet. C'est pas de la moustache.
Et vous, vous vous prenez pour le comité de validation
des plus beaux jours de la vie des gens, normal ?
Vous parlez de quoi ?
Non mais laisse, c'est lui qui raconte
n'importe quoi depuis tout à l'heure là.
Toi t'es chaud en nœud de cravate, non ?
Ouais.
Je suis en train de me dire, le nœud pap'...
ça fait peut-être "too much", tu vois ?
Toi là, c'est quoi le plus beau jour de ta vie ?
Bah...
alors c'est vrai que déjà euh...
elle est pas finie finie ma vie...
mais je pense que le plus beau jour de ma vie...
ce serait...
C'est trop mignon !
Mais c'était il y a dix minutes !
Qui vit son plus beau jour il y a dix minutes ?
C'est normal, c'est ma meilleure pote !
Bah ta vie, elle est éclatée.
Ton plus beau jour de ta vie, il est calqué
sur ce qui est censé être son plus beau jour à elle.
T'as un plus beau jour de ta vie par procuration toi.
C'est bon, on peut y aller maintenant ?
Ok, madame "j'ai un vieux plus beau jour de ma life".
Et voilà, t'es tout frais mon frère !
C'est cool.
Merde ! L'alliance putain...
Adam, Adam !
Il est plus tendu que toi.
Oh ! Qu'est-ce qu'il t'arrive ?
Pourquoi depuis tout à l'heure, t'arrêtes pas de me parler
comme si j'en avais rien à foutre de mon mariage en fait ?
Oh là ! T'énerve pas.
Je me pose la question, c'est tout.
Moi je pensais qu'aujourd'hui,
ça serait le plus beau jour de ta vie.
Ah ouais ?
Et pourquoi ça te paraît logique
que ce soit le plus beau jour de ma vie aujourd'hui ?
C'est parce que je suis une femme, c'est ça ?
Non.
Donc le mariage, c'est censé être le plus beau jour de ma vie ?
Et après, ça sera quoi?
La naissance de mon premier gosse, je suppose ?
Bon...
Tout est bon, on va pouvoir y aller.
Bah on va demander à Arthur,
comme ça je serai pas le grand frère misogyne.
Aujourd'hui, c'est bien le plus beau jour de ta vie ?
Euh... non.
Je crois, mon plus beau jour...
c'est quand je l'ai demandée en mariage mec.
C'était ouf !
Wah !
T'as fait ta demande par SMS !
Et toi, t'as accepté ?
Mais oui, c'était trop mignon !
Il avait mis des emojis, ça a tout changé !
Tu vois ? J'ai pas besoin d'un plus beau jour de ma vie.
J'en veux juste plusieurs comme ça.
On y va ?
On est ici pour célébrer l'union de deux personnes que j'aime.
Rien de servile,
quand il s'agit de servir un frérot pas de problème.
Ils se sont vus, ils se sont aimés de manière instantanée.
Un idylle qui a vu le jour il y a quelques années.
Pourquoi ils sont tellement liés
qu'on dirait qu'ils se connaissent depuis qu'ils sont nés ?
L'un est verseau, l'autre est lion.
Recto verso pour ce couple digne du roi lion.
Nala et Simba s'aiment jusqu'à ce que Scar les sépare.
Pas de cicatrice pour ce couple qui est maintenant marié.
J'ai nommé Naïma et Arthur, ils vont dénoncer la pièce.
Ils vont... ils vont démonter la pièce...
Adam, t'es là ?
Oui, non. Si !
J'arr... j'arrive.